it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning as we approach the
fourth weekend of the war in ukraine
there are reports this morning of
explosions in the western city of the
viv it comes with more accusations from
the west that russia
is committing war crimes we will be
speaking to the armed forces minister
james heaping in just a few minutes time
it is friday the 18th of march
a series of missiles strike the western
ukrainian city of lev the mayor there
says an aircraft maintenance plant has
been destroyed
fake news russia's ambassador to the u.n
tells sky vladimir putin's forces did
not bomb a ukrainian theater where
civilians were sheltering
we have this information which is raging
much much
on a much greater scale than the than
the battle than on the battlefield and i
will not be surprised at anything
because
who wins the the information the one
meanwhile in the southern port city of
odessa residents prepare for a russian
attack that could come from the sea
homes for ukraine the new scheme to
house refugees opens but the government
is accused of not supporting british
hosts
mutiny on the ferries angry
demonstrations are planned against
piano's decision to sack 800 workers on
the spot
freedom to roam all remaining covered
travel measures are axed for people
coming into the uk as part of the
government's plan to live with covet
and eager beavers in the capital they're
back in london for the first time in
more than 400 years
also ahead on the program this hour
an emergency mission i'll be catching up
with the scottish student who bought an
ambulance and drove it all the way to
the ukrainian border
[Music]
and music for the monarchy i'll be
speaking to the russian-born royal
composer about her new piece the queen's
platinum jubilee and just what her
childhood was like growing up in russia
[Music]
morning all and we begin with some
breaking news there are reports of
multiple explosions in the western
ukrainian city of levitt this morning
within the past arm the city's mayor has
confirmed that missiles destroyed an
aircraft maintenance plant at sky's
alastair bunkel is in la viv in western
ukraine for us this morning alistair
just tell us what what you heard and
what you saw
yeah money neal so the airaid sirens
went off at around 6 15 in the morning i
mean that's been commonplace over the
last week or so here
but then
three or four
explosions i counted around 6 30
a.m in the morning here so
just really as the city was starting to
wake up just as the curfew had lifted um
we're at the airport now or as close as
we can get the airport the authorities
are pretty jittery uh they don't really
want to uh broadcast around the world
the damage that's been done
because they don't want that sort of
propaganda for the russians
but
behind these buildings is where the
airport complex is uh smoke has been
coming from there for for most of the
morning it's starting to dissipate now
the initials thought was that they hit
the airport itself because we'd been
expecting that actually as a strategic
target of the russians but actually
we're now being told that it was a site
just next door uh an aviation repair
facility uh that one assumes is part of
the ukrainian war effort to keep their
fighter jets in the skies
in terms of what where and how uh
reports again of russian strategic
bombers were around the area in the
early hours of this morning so i think
probably that's where the strikes came
from it's not going to be an artillery
barrier or anything like that the
russian forces just aren't anywhere near
here to be able to carry that kind of
attack out so i think we're looking at
probably some long-range cruise missiles
uh precision strikes
alastair many thanks indeed and we'll
have much more from alastair throughout
the program of course uh but also this
morning russia's ambassador to the
united nations has told sky news
vladimir putin's forces had nothing to
do with an attack on a theater in the
ukrainian city of mario paul where up to
a thousand civilians were believed to
have been sheltering vaseline india
claims there's an information war taking
place on a larger scale than on the
battlefield or the other main
developments this morning the uk's
ambassador to the un dame barbara
woodward has told sky news the war in
ukraine is being characterized by
russian disinformation
and that it's important to keep the
pressure on vladimir putin
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has warned foreign mercenaries
against fighting for russia saying it
would be the worst decision of their
lives
the minister of defense intelligence
reports that russian forces have made
minimal progress this week and that
ukrainian defenses around kiev and
mykolov continue to frustrate attempts
to encircle uh zolensky's forces
and more than 150 000 people have
registered for the uk homes for ukraine
scheme which launches today our u.s
correspondent martha kellner reports
from the u.n in new york
as ukraine burns the united nations the
body whose founding principle is to
avoid horror like this talks and the
condemnation of russia grows louder
russia has attacked so much of what we
hold sacred
and everything
everything
the united nations stands for as one of
five permanent security council members
russia has equal standing here the power
of veto and for its ambassador the
platform to peddle this information
ambassador i have colleagues who are out
in ukraine who have seen with their own
eyes the atrocities being committed by
russia in ukraine you've been in the
united states the whole time who's more
likely to know what exactly is going on
look
what kind of atrocities you're referring
to i'm talking about narrow trenches in
mario paul with babies bodies in i'm
talking about theaters in mario paul
being bombed by russia
the theater in mariopol was not born by
russia
i spoke about it and you may refer to my
statement i do not know anything about
the trenches with
killed babies in it i haven't seen it ap
ap journalists have been there since so
many fakes
we have this information which is raging
much much on on a much greater scale
than the than the battle then on the
battlefield and i will not be surprised
at anything because
who wins the the information world the
one wins do you do you really truly
believe this
[Music]
but these pictures tell the true story
this is the aftermath of that bombing of
the theater in mariupol where hundreds
of people including children were
sheltering
the british ambassador to the un says
their stories must be told to expose
russian lies
the russians say
that they are attacking military targets
they're actually attacking children who
are sheltering and that's a war crime we
heard it from president biden yesterday
we've heard it from the secretary of
state anthony blinken today you agree
with that that vladimir putin is a war
criminal we're certainly agreeing that
there are war crimes being committed in
ukraine they have to be investigated of
course by the relevant international
legal authorities but really the main
thing that we need to do now is stop the
war get russian boots off the ground and
return ukraine to
peace
at the u.n russia has called a meeting
today on what they say are u.s bio
weapons in ukraine it is another
baseless claim another attempt to
deflect from the atrocities being
inflicted on these innocent people
martha kellner sky news new york
joining us once again on the program the
armed forces minister james heavy
minister always good to have you on the
program and as always lots for us to
discuss so let's let let's start shall
we with the kind of the overview of
where the conflict is currently the dod
and the mod seem to be an agreement that
the russians have made precious little
advance over the past week but i'm
wondering whether or not you are
concerned about what we've just seen in
the past few years in la viv what
appears to be the use of cruise missiles
to take out part of the airport facility
yeah i mean i think that's exactly right
nile that
on the sort of macro level when you look
at the whole map the russians are making
very very little progress and yet they
continue to expend a significant amount
of military resource uh and
that is great credit to the resistance
the ukrainians are putting up
but on the sort of on the the sort of
smaller more local level what's going on
in mario paul is a cause for huge
concern the city is uh under a level of
barrage that is utterly terrifying and
disastrous for the population that
remains there the ukrainian mps that
visited me here in the ministry of
defence yesterday uh were telling me
that maybe 90 percent of the city is now
being uh affected um and as you say you
know the there are now two strikes into
western ukraine the air base last week
and uh and strikes nova last night um so
whilst there's no macro progress
we're very concerned about the suffering
of the people in mario polo and other
cities that are under siege in the east
and the fact that ukrainian supply lines
are starting to be attacked in the west
it it certainly looks that there has
been a tactic of blanket bombardment
when it comes to mario paul in terms of
the russian strategy there you'll have
heard just in the past couple of minutes
though
in martha's report the russian
ambassador to to the united nations
denying any russian involvement in what
happened in that theater in mario paul
what is our intelligence telling us
about responsibility
i don't know how the russian ambassador
sleeps at night because you know he sits
there he stands there and he says that
to your correspondent that it is
it is clear as day what's happening in
in mario paul the russians are
indiscriminately
using uh artillery and missile strikes
to um to destroy a city that they were
unable to take militarily and
the resistance that remains in there is
courageous the problem is is that mario
paul is probably the worst it's the one
that we're most concerned about but
actually
there's not dissimilar things happening
in kharkiv
uh as well and other places besides um
this is a barbaric tactic the russians
have failed to do this militarily they
thought that they could do it in days
and what it looks like they're going to
try to do is to encircle these cities
and just then use artillery
and missile strikes in order to
to to force the ukrainians into
submission but the ukrainians so no sign
of doing that and that's to their
enormous credit
um mr hippy you and i have spoken enough
enough times that i know that you choose
your words very carefully so just to
pick you up in some of the things that
you said there barbaric tactics you know
it's clear as day what the russians are
doing there how does the russian
ambassador to the u.n uh sleep at night
is this now not the point for us to do
what the american president has done
and call vladimir putin what he
apparently is a war criminal a murderous
dictator a pure thug well i mean i've
not pulled my punches when i've been on
your um on your show previously and i
think that the evidence that is uh that
is being gathered points very much
towards uh war crimes being committed in
ukraine and the culpability for war
crimes sits absolutely with the leader
of the russian government the man who
decided to do all of this in the first
place but the other point to make and
it's an important point to make is that
it's not just putin who ends up being
responsible for war crimes as and when
the evidence is gathered and people are
held to account every single person in
the military of chain of command cannot
just hide behind the line of their only
following orders they too are involved
in the prosecution of war crimes in
ukraine this is uh a stay
on uh on the russian nation and i know
because i can i see information about
some of the questions that russians are
asking on on on search platforms um you
know russians are
questioning whether or not the behavior
of their presidents and their armed
forces um is quite how it's being
presented to them on the russian media
and the answer is it's not they're
russia the russian armed forces are
letting the russian people down their
president is letting the russian people
down
given what we we've seen in mario paul
and indeed as you mentioned in a lot of
other places around ukraine it does
perhaps feel like we're putting the cat
before the horse but people are
beginning to talk about
how the conflict may well come to an end
and discussions seem to be in part
centering around the west you know the
united kingdom france the americans and
others somehow guaranteeing ukraine's
safety in the future i mean isn't that
just nato membership by another name
i don't think so i mean i think we've
got to be we've got to be clear that
this
can't go on indefinitely that the thing
that all of us want
is not the the the endless arming of the
ukrainians so that they can resist as
necessary as that is for as long as the
fighting continues we don't want the
ukrainians to
have to lose or to give up their country
but what we do need clearly is a
situation in which the two sides meet
and come to some sort of arrangement if
the west has a role to play
alongside others beyond the region in
brokering that piece and
offering something that uh that the
ukrainians and the russians can live
with that's fine but what i absolutely
don't think we should do and i've heard
some uh around the west suggest this is
that somehow ukraine should be pressured
to give up the donbass or to uh to to
give up its claim on the crimea those
are decisions entirely for president
zielenski and his government uh it's not
for the west to trade away ukrainian
sovereignty
i do want to speak about piano uh
ferries in just a second but finally
just on the on this topic
what are we to make of the fact that
that a prank caller you know a foreign
agent was able to spend eight nine
minutes on a video call with the
secretary of state for defense at a time
when you know we are we are actively
assisting another country in its war
well i think that the secretary of state
has asked some pretty tough questions of
the department as to how that was able
to happen he acknowledges very much that
it shouldn't have done but ben is
is a guy that understands uh threat very
well he spent a long time as our
nation's security minister before he was
promoted to be the secretary of state he
was acutely aware that he was on uh
microsoft teams call
and therefore
he would not ever
disclose any sensitive details on a
platform that can be very easily uh
intercepted and listened into
and the call therefore was
pretty bland i think from what ben was
explaining to me last night and when the
call started to ask more pointed
questions about
our intentions militarily in the region
um ben knew full well that that's not
the sort of question that anybody would
normally ask
on teams
and so he became pretty suspicious and
terminated the court
and let's talk then and piano fairies a
huge story and on any other day would
would be our lead story at what point
did piano ferries if at all at what
point did they inform the government
that they were about to take what
frankly some people are describing as
you know employer relations from the
19th century
yeah it's disgraceful i i mean to be
honest with you now as far as i know
from
colleagues around government uh they i
don't think the government got much more
noticed than the employees of piano did
and my great friend robert courts the
transport minister was in the commons
yesterday and i could see from the
expression on his face just how angry he
was at the way that piano had handled
this um most importantly for the people
who were fired but actually just it's
shoddy to to to do that and to not give
the department for transport any notice
the fact you're going to do it because
he would have wanted i think to have
been involved in a discussion to try to
persuade piano to do things differently
is it the case then that there is pretty
much nothing that can be done then from
a government perspective about those 800
individuals it's time for them to you
know i don't know seek employment
tribunals
so sadly it is the case that the
government cannot force an employer to
continue to employ people that the
employer has said it doesn't want to to
employ
but ordinarily in these situations a
company would come to the government in
fact
often companies come to the government
way before they actually need to do
anything because they're just constantly
lobbying for more support in piano's
case it seems that they had made their
decision entirely under their own steam
uh and the dft were told about the same
time as the people working for piano
absolutely horrendous way to treat their
staff um there's and i know there's a
lot of anger amongst ministerial
colleagues in the department for
transport they're seeing what they can
do to try to make the situation better
but the reality is is that p have made a
commercial decision um and as much as we
disagree with it um i i fear that for
those uh for those workers um they've
been badly let down by their employer
minister i've got to let you go so you
can answer this as quickly or as slowly
as you like um you know we gave them 10
million pounds in terms of for low money
can we get that back from piano ferries
oh no i don't know i mean it sounds like
exactly the sort of thing that um that
if i were the treasury i would be asking
for but um but i i don't know exactly
how these things work i'm afraid i'm
sorry you've got enough on your plate as
it is minister always good to have you
in the program thanks for being with me
thank you very much thank you
let's take a quick look then at some of
the front pages from the papers let's
stop the guardian it says that russia is
now being accused by several countries
including britain of committing war
crimes after its bombing of a school and
a theater where people were sheltering
the eye reports that vladimir putin may
have to abandon his planned tank assault
on kiev because of the strong resistance
his forces are meeting uh however we've
seen seen it take place in lev he may
well instead increase the use of
rocketry at rockets and artillery
bombardment instead at the telegraph it
says that the home secretary and the
defense secretary pretty patel and ben
wallace were well as you were just
hearing in my interview with mr keepy
targeted by russian impostors posing as
ukrainian politicians and video calls
and the ft leads with the decision by p
and o ferries to sack 800 people and
replace them with cheaper labor the
staff were fired via a zoom call with
immediate effect
still to come on the show
general sir richard sheriff will be
joining me to join give us his analysis
on the war in ukraine so far
and just what vladimir putin might do
next
i'll be hearing from the greater
manchester fire and rescue service ahead
of their journey to deliver equipment to
firefighters in ukraine
[Music]
and after p made 800 people redundant
via video message i'll be speaking to
travel expert simon holder
residents in the southern port city of
odessa are preparing for a possible
russian attack that could come from the
sea uh joining us now nick martin
actually in odessa forest nick good to
see you looks awfully calm and quiet
over your shoulders i suspect just a
little bit further out of shot perhaps
not so much so
yeah good morning neil um imagine being
a resident here in this city you know a
month ago things were perfectly normal
no sign of any trouble at all and now
there are people standing out on the
coast looking out at these small dots on
the horizon hazy little dots and that's
a flotilla of russian battleships
imagine that one of the largest navies
in the world staring back right at you
well that's what the people of odessa
are facing now there is some hope though
um the there are there are intelligence
suggests
to say that there is no evidence to show
that there are the russian navy are
planning an amphibious attack just yet
although those uh intelligence reports
i'm sure will start to change
over the coming weeks but that threat
lurks on the horizon for the people of
this city and they just have to to live
with that for the moment
just in the last few minutes on on the
attack in la viv in in the west the
ukrainian military uh have said to us
that they believe that that attack was
uh caused by a cruise missile now for
those who don't know what cruise
missiles are these are very
sophisticated weapons long-range jet
propelled
guided weapons and that is uh perhaps
proof that the russians are prepared to
use long-range weaponry on attack on
cities like lev
we were there last week and i can tell
you that that city is full of refugees
as people have started to move from the
east to the west the mayor last week
said it was full so goodness knows what
it's like now the russians we suspect
also seen as a major route in for
supplies and that is why perhaps we have
seen that attack from long-range guided
missiles in la viv this morning attacks
also in kiev overnight and so a lot has
happened overnight significant that the
viv has been struck
nick many thanks indeed
p and o ferries uh well as we've been
reporting they have fired around 800
staff without a minutes warning via
video message the company claims it
faces unsustainable losses and wants to
replace existing staff with cheaper
agency workers uh skies shingi maruriki
is in dover for us this morning good to
see you shingi uh we're going to be
expecting some some fairly substantial
fallout i suspect from the decision made
by piano ferries and and not just as
regards those 800 employees i mean are
the ferries sailing today
morning neil so the ferries are not
sailing today and it will remain that
way over the course of the next few days
at least and to put into context just
how angry people are before that has
already begun rmt the union representing
staff and seafarers who work for pno
called it one of the most shameful acts
in the history of british industrial
relations like you say members of staff
laid off over a zoom call yesterday and
that provoked significant anger and fury
among those members of staff piano it's
interesting that there are strong legal
implications here piano took the
decision because they say that they were
experiencing catastrophic year-on-year
losses of 100 million pounds the impact
of the pandemic as well as brexit and
the confusion around the northern
ireland protocol just some of the things
that were causing money to fall for
funny to fall through their pockets but
that proposal to cut 20 or more jobs
must come under consultation according
to pno's own rules of course this is 800
members of staff who are being laid off
meaning that the employees could
potentially bring a claim of unfair
dismissal but the anger has already
begun yesterday across the ports that
piano operate across staff essentially
staged sit-ins they didn't leave those
boats and members of of security
services who were equipped with
handcuffs had to come and take them off
the boats according to reports protests
are arranged for here liverpool and
whole today so it's quite clear that the
anger over those abrupt dismissals will
continue today
shingeki many thanks indeed
let's take a quick look at some of the
day's other headlines now and president
baden will discuss his concerns over
china's stance about the war in ukraine
with president xi jinping later today
the united states is worried that
beijing may soon be providing military
aid to moscow
a report from a group of mps has
concluded that ministers failed to allow
parliament enough scrutiny of the
sweeping laws passed to tackle the
coveted pandemic the coronavirus act
2020 granted ministers a wide range of
emergency powers including postponement
of local elections powers to shut down
schools and order the cancellation of
public gatherings
all covered travel restrictions for
people coming into the uk have now been
lifted including the passenger locator
form
unvaccinated travelers will also no
longer need to take a pre-departure test
and a day two post-arrival test
currently a beautiful day here in
westminster how is it where you are
let's find out
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather sponsored by qatar airways
and for a merely fine few days but the
showers will spread into the south on
sunday with the southeast looking most
at risk mostly sunny but quite chilly at
the moment with a frost in places and
fog in the south just a few showers in
the far north the morning will be mostly
dry and sunny with early fog and showers
in the north soon clear clearing but
misty low cloud will affect southern
irish coasts it will be mainly mild very
mild in fact for england and wales
generally light breezes mean it should
feel pleasant in the sunshine but a
stiff wind in the northwest will make it
feel colder there
quick reminder as to our top stories and
piano ferries have defended their
decision to make more than 800 staff
redundant with almost no warning
the mayor of lev says a series of
missiles have destroyed an air an
airplane maintenance plant near the
city's airport
and russia's ambassador to the united
nations tells sky news vladimir putin's
forces did not bomb a ukrainian theater
where civilians were sheltered
let's stick with that topic shall we
russia's ambassador to the united
nations has told sky news vladimir
putin's forces had nothing to do with
the attack on a theater in the ukrainian
city of manipal where as many as a
thousand civilians were believed to have
been sheltering just a little earlier i
asked the armed forces minister james
heapey about those claims by the
russians and he well frankly didn't hold
back
i don't know how the russian ambassador
sleeps at night because you know he sits
there he stands there and he says that
to your correspondent that it is
it is clear as day what's happening in
in mario paul the russians are
indiscriminately
using
artillery and missile strikes to
to destroy a city that they were unable
to take militarily and
the resistance that remains in there is
courageous the problem is is that mario
pole is probably the worst it's the one
that we're most concerned about but
actually um there's not dissimilar
things happening in kharkiv sumi uh as
well and other spaces besides
joining us now our skateboarding
correspondent sorry political
correspondent rob powell you are
recovered from your injury now rob you
put it on social media so i'm allowed to
mention it publicly but let's focus
shall we on the at the interview with
the armed forces minister yeah he didn't
hold back but he certainly didn't go as
far as you know the president of the
united states and his condemnation
no still not neil making that explicit
link as president biden did and calling
vladimir putin a war criminal instead
saying that uh it certainly uh was clear
that war crimes had been committed and
that the evidence pointed towards not
just president putin but others within
the russian establishment as well but
very strong words responding to the
russian ambassador who told sky news at
the un overnight that russia wasn't
responsible for the bombing of that
theater in mario paul saying it was
clear as day what was happening
there he also expressed concern as well
about what we've been learning from
western ukraine in the last few hours uh
missile strikes that appear to have
taken place close to the airport there
saying that it was concerning that it
appeared that supply routes into ukraine
appear now to be targeted
by russian forces we also got uh his
view um and some more information as
well on one big domestic story we've
been covering in the last 24 hours uh
those 800 redundancies being made um by
piano ferries james hippie again not
holding back saying it was shoddy and
disgraceful what piano had done that
they didn't give the government much
more notice than they did to the workers
that's crucial that's important because
that suggests that they may well have
broken employment law if they hadn't
given that notification to the
government but again james heapey saying
that this was a commercial decision to
saying that there really wasn't all that
much that the government could do to get
involved in this
but did float the idea when you put it
to him of looking again at some of the
furlough cash during the pandemic
that was given um to the company
and i think there will be pressure for
the government to look at whatever
leverage it has with the firm
whether that does mean furlough cash or
whether that does mean uh reviewing and
looking again at some of the contracts
that the government has with pna
rob good to have you back thanks for
joining us
now the ministry of defence has released
its daily intelligence report about
ukraine it concludes the russian forces
have made little to no progress this
week and the ukrainian forces are
continuing to frustrate any advancements
uh here to give his analysis of the
situation general sir richard sheriff
former deputy supreme allied commander
of nato general great to have you on the
programme this morning um i wonder if we
can start with with that mod assessment
and indeed the assessment of the
department of defense uh the russians
for all their efforts over the past week
really have not been making gains
uh well good morning and and and yes i'm
sure that the assessment is absolutely
correct
um what we've seen is an extraordinarily
brave tenacious courageous uh ukrainian
defense fired by the spirit to defend
their country
they've been well supported by the west
with anti-tank weapons anti-aircraft
missiles and the like and they're
showing that they can use them but we've
also seen extraordinary incompetence and
lack of professionalism by the russian
armed forces
they spread their forces too thin
they've failed to support them
logistically they've forgotten that
fundamental maxim of war that amateurs
talk tactics and professionals talk
logistics
uh morale by all accounts among the
russian soldiers is absolutely rock
bottom they were expecting to be greeted
by
uh by by flag waving crowds and they've
been greeted by ferocious defense
um but herein so they say it's
absolutely going uh the ukrainian way
and the ukrainians have inflicted really
significant uh attrition on on the
russians
but herein lies the issue which is that
of course putin cannot accept defeat
and therefore uh in typical kgb style
if he's facing trouble in one direction
he could cause even greater trouble in
another
well very specifically then
general what do you mean by that where
might vladimir putin's gays fall upon
next well we should be
absolutely on our guard to for example
chemical attack
um
uh
quite potentially
the use of of tactical nuclear uh and
quite potentially the the uh some sort
of uh attack against nato territory
we've already seen
uh putin targeting uh ukrainian
infrastructure supply routes through the
attack last week on the last weekend
um and i think all bets and everything
should be on the table and we should be
very very clear about what might happen
and take the necessary measures to guard
against it in particular i think the
most important thing is
really effective nato conventional
deterrence we're seeing a ramp up of
nato troops on the eastern flank as a
deterrent force nato of course remains
defensive
and i think that ramp up of false should
continue because we can take nothing for
granted
are we now at the point
given that which we've seen in mariopol
the bombing of the theater the russian
ambassador to the united nations denying
any responsibility but as we heard from
james sippy just a little bit earlier
all the evidence suggests russian
involvement you know
are we now at the point of perhaps
considering whether or not there should
be a more active nato involvement in the
situation in ukraine the norfolk zone
has always been ruled out but but given
the human rights atrocities that we are
seeing is it perhaps time to revisit
that decision
i
completely understand the
horrified response uh to the atrocities
being committed by by russian forces um
and of course every
fiber in us says we want to respond we
want to do what we can to support but we
have to think really clearly here
because any nato direct action on the
ground in the air in ukraine
is an act of war a a no-fly zone would
involve the shooting down of russian
aircraft the the
destruction of russian air defense
batteries and and radars on the ground
if nato goes down this line it has to be
clear
that it is ready and prepared to fight a
general war against russia because that
is where it would lead
and a general war
that could easily go nuclear and
therefore become a war of national
survival so we need to be crystal clear
about the implications before we make
any decisions like this
given what we have heard however from
from from the american president joe
biden you know he made absolutely clear
there'd be no american troops on the
ground appeared to intimate that it
would take well i'm not quite sure what
it would take for a military conflict to
exist between the united states and
russia but it would take an awful lot do
you think we have been sending that
message clearly enough
i think it's been pretty clear but let's
also be clear that it a nato a russian
incursion into nato territory
would mean all 30 member states of nato
would be at war with russia
because nato is founded on the principle
of collective defense an attack on one
is an attack on all
and that is precisely what we have to
guard against so yes to support ukraine
with weaponry and the like uh yes to um
the the the economic sanctions that are
clearly really hitting russia hard
but
thus far no further as far as nato is
concerned
general sir richard chef great to have
you on the program this morning really
appreciate your time
thank you
people across the uk have been finding
different ways to help support the
efforts in ukraine whether it's signing
up to home refugees or just donating a
few bits and bobs now greater
manchester's fire and rescue service are
joining a national convoy to deliver
thousands of items of kit and equipment
to support firefighters on the front
line
joining us now david russell and steve
jordan from greater manchester fire and
rescue service gentlemen good to have
you on the programme and steve i hope
you don't mind i'm going to start with
the gaff of the chief fire officer
just to try and take us through exactly
what it is that you guys will be
delivering to the ukrainians what are
you taking out there
we're forming part of a national
convoy which will see upwards of
um 20 fire engines and over 5000 items
of equipment which will be
provided to support firefighters in
ukraine so that is a national response
what we're providing from greater
manchester fire and rescue service is
two fire engines
a hydraulic platform and many items of
equipment and we're joined today by
colleagues from lancashire and
merseyside which will be providing the
north west response
as part of the national deployment
steve you're actually going to be part
of the convoy i'm told how you how are
you feeling about the journey that's
fast approaching
yeah no very good thanks very much uh
it's been a lot of work behind the
scenes so
uh myself the manchester team and the
lancashire merseyside team uh
uh are pleased to actually get to this
point now and be able to actually uh get
on on board the convoy and be able to
deliver the aid well we will keep
fingers crossed on that but david you
know i've known a few firefighters in my
time and the camaraderie that exists
between firefighters extends way beyond
you know national boundaries you know if
you're a firefighter in another part of
the world you guys will get on there
there is a shared experience there but i
wonder how you feel about the the
bravery the courage that's been shown by
your colleagues in ukraine working you
know as we've said quite literally
on the front line of a war
we're we're in incredibly proud and i
think um
today represents fire and rescue
services at their best what we do is
help people and we support
communities and the whole fire service
family has been moved by the scenes
we've seen in ukraine with firefighters
dealing with some really difficult
building fires collapse structures and
you know we're just proud that as a as a
uk fire
organization we're able to provide vital
appliances and equipment so you know
we want to help um and and today is he's
a is a step towards that
um steve of course you
you won't be allowed to to head into
ukraine proper i'm sure you'll be taking
this stuff
you're as close as you as close as you
can but is there perhaps
a little part of you that might wish to
be out there actually helping on the
front line alongside your ukrainian
colleagues
yeah of course i mean
as as uh my chief has just said there
the firefighters see themselves as a as
a family
uh you know whenever we see a
firefighter that's uh fallen we feel a
sense of uh tremendous grief so uh the
fact that we're seeing firefighters on
the front line every day and that's
obviously covered in the uh in the media
is is something that um we all feel
strongly about of course we would like
that opportunity but uh realistically in
this sort of situation and scenario it's
it's our priority is really to to get
that aid there i think the key thing is
is we will also be linking up and
hooking up with our colleagues from the
polish fire service as well
so whatever we do we know that it's it's
going to have a tremendous impact uh and
support for our ukrainian colleagues
um and david just to conclude with you
just just give us an idea you'll have
obviously been liaising as a as steve
was just saying that with with the polls
and indeed with your colleagues in
ukraine
what have they been telling you about
the work that they are having to do at
the moment as mentioned before they are
in the middle of a war it is a dangerous
enough job that you guys do at the best
of times but to be doing it out there
under those circumstances and i'm just
wondering what they've been telling you
about about how they've been coping
well what we do know is is that
firefighters in ukraine are dealing with
some incredibly difficult
situations which is obviously stretching
their resources
very much so
the resources which fire rescue services
nationally are providing will
absolutely support and complement their
access to fire engines
and equipment so you know that that will
will help but undoubtedly it is
difficult really to comprehend how
difficult it is for firefighters in
in in in ukraine but as a as a nation of
firefighters you know we support
everybody out there on the front line
uh well look wishing you a very very
safe journey out there and a safe return
trip as well uh david russell steve
jordan from greater manchester fire and
rescue service thanks so much for
joining us guys
now demonstrations are expected today
after piano ferries laid off 800 members
of staff via video message and without
any prior warning a little earlier the
armed forces minister james heap told us
it was a horrendous way to treat people
i'm sure someone who will agree with
that the travel editor at the
independent simon calder simon lovely to
see you as always um let us start there
are a number of things we need to talk
about today but let us start with with p
and o ferries why did they take this
particular decision i understand the
travel sector as we have discussed over
the past couple of years have really had
a time of it but to sack 800 people in
this way is giving them an awful lot of
negative pr this morning
well it certainly is now let's just bear
in mind that piano ferries which by the
way has no connection with piano cruises
which is sailing perfectly normally and
isn't involved in this it's an american
oak company piano ferries is odd world a
dubai based company now over the past
year we have been told that they've lost
roughly 100 million pounds that's three
pounds per second clearly unsustainable
many many companies have suffered in the
travel industry as you uh say over the
past two years and a lot of those have
come up with well what's been described
as fire and re-hire the idea that you
negotiate with your existing workforce
and say well if you want to stay working
you're going to have to accept inferior
terms and conditions if you look at an
airline like british airways they've
done that and pretty much all the pilots
the cabin crew who are working there
today are on much worse terms than they
were three years ago but this was all
negotiated with the union
dp world
appears to have instructed piano ferries
right just sack everybody we've got
other um staff waiting they will be able
to take over uh we'll resume the
operation well they're gonna say in a
few hours they're now saying maybe a
week or so and um everything will carry
on as normal as we've seen from the
outrage right across the political
spectrum that simply isn't working and
um while it's been awful talking to
many of the seafarers here in dover in
the past 24 hours they're total shock
that they were sacked in this way i
think that they may have some good news
i hope um uh it very quickly because i
think piano has simply misjudged this
appallingly
uh well simon we will we will wait and
see what the response may well be from
from pno but just in terms of the
practical consequences of what we have
seen what does this mean for people who
are due to be traveling over the next
few days and indeed we probably
shouldn't forget the fact you know the
ports are going to get awfully awfully
crowded if there are no piano ferries
leaving for the next few days
well look at steven i'm just looking
across and uh the the jubilee way which
is the overpass that comes down from the
white cliffs of dover looking pretty
clear this morning um yesterday
it was uh really quite niled up with a
lot of trucks but what's happening is
that people booked on piano from here
are being moved on to dfps ferries um
there's also a
capacity from irish ferries sailing from
here to calais and then of course just
10 years 10 miles or so down the road
folks and you've got euro tunnel so
there's enough capacity at the moment
we're not into the busy easter holidays
with lots of leisure traffic yet at the
other ports it's a different story uh
hull to rotterdam there is no easy
alternative you've got newcastle to
amsterdam or parish to hook of holland
but piano is basically just saying well
if you if you're booked on that route
then then probably best not to travel
same applies cairn ryan's alarm the
shortest scotland to northern ireland
crossing um some people are uh
booking with stena line from uh
ken ryan to
belfast although they've got limited
capacity they're doing what they can to
help and of course liverpool to dublin
is the other one so it is very very
messy in the short term um it's one of
those things though that one reason uh
pno has lost so much money is there is
such intense competition in
the the uh ferry industry keeping us
connected with the rest of europe
and simon a word from you on covet
travel restrictions or indeed lack
thereof some good news for travellers
trying to get away over the easter
yes um we have found from the for almost
the past four hours anybody arriving by
sea by rail or by air to the uk
no longer has to fill in that pesky
passenger locator form and i think even
more significant for people who have not
been vaccinated um there is no need to
be tested either before you leave for
the uk or when you arrive now when he
announced all this earlier in the week
the transport secretary grant chat says
you can travel like you did before well
i'm afraid it's not quite the same
that the case because of course the vast
majority of destinations worldwide have
their own restrictions and therefore you
have to fit in with those rules whether
they're filling in forms proving you've
been vaccinated taking uh tests before
or uh you go or on you when you arrive
but um certainly in terms of coming back
into the uk it is now much easier and
you just go back three months or so we
still had hotel quarantine everybody
needed to self-isolate when they got
back to the uk so a complete
transformation the travel industry is
apart from of course from piano ferries
being a bit cheerier uh this morning and
the hope is that other countries are
going to get rid of these and we will be
able to uh enjoy something like normal
life in terms of travel but with there's
still some way to go
that is just a little bit isn't that um
simon always a pleasure to talk to you
looks like a wonderful day down there in
dover do enjoy it as much as you can
thanks for joining us
but you can stay right where you are
coming up in the next hour of sky news
breakfast we will of course have much
much more from in and around ukraine the
mayor of lev says a series of missiles
have destroyed an airplane maintenance
plant near the city's airport the
significance of leve as it is all the
way over in the west of the country very
very close to the polish border
we will at the top of the next i'll be
speaking to our special correspondent
alex crawford from inside ukraine
[Music]
you